最近贝克汉姆一家公开决裂
把一个原本只存在于无数
普通家庭里边的
赤裸裸的摊在了聚光灯下
一个儿子
公开控诉自己的父母
不是说几句情绪化的抱怨
而是十几条条理清晰
情绪克制但锋利的指控啊
把品牌和形象放在亲情之上
最终
这孩子说了一句让
无数人心头一震的话
他说
和我的家族断联之后
我第一次感到平静
很多人的第一反应可能是愤怒
他怎么能这么对父母啊
父母再怎么不完美
也是为他好啊
这不就是忘恩负义吗
但如果你真的从心理学的角度去看
你会发现
这并不是一场简单的家庭断裂
而是一种极其典型
也正在全球范围内发生的心理现象
我们把它叫做
仇亲并不是说恨父母本身
他真正针对的就是这种
长期
却被要求感恩的那种关系结构
所以今天我们就来从心理学的角度聊一聊
欢迎来到
在心理学上
有一个非常重要的这么一个概念
叫做
当一个孩子在家庭
里边长期处于这种状态
比如说情感被忽略
但功能被高度的利用
决定权被剥夺
却被要求成熟懂事
个人边界被反复的侵犯
却被说成不懂事
不感恩
爱是有条件的
听话体面配合
你才配被爱
那这个人的内在
就会逐渐形成一种极深的撕裂感
我靠近你
我就会失去我自己
但是我离开你
我又会被整个世界指责
那你看在这种长期的拉扯里边
仇亲
并不是主动选择的情绪
而是自我系统为了活下来被迫
启动的这种极端的保护机制
不是说因为不爱
而是因为再不反抗
我就要
所以你们看在贝克汉姆的家庭里边
真正致命的不是冲突
而是
如果你仔细看一看
布鲁克林写的这些控诉
你就会发现一个反复
出现的核心的感受
就是
无论是婚礼座位的安排
婚纱是否由母亲决定
婚前的商业协定
是否能带妻子出席家庭的活动
哪怕婚礼上的第一支舞
能不能我和我的老婆来跳
是否有权利定义谁是家人
你看表面上看都是
一件件具体的事吧
但是在心理层面
他们全部指向了同一件事
就是
在家庭系统理论里边
有一个极其危险的结构
叫做
这种家庭的核心价值它不是情感
而是
那在这种家庭里边
孩子就很容易被无意识的
当成三种东西之一
第一个
你只是家庭形象的延伸
第二
你是成功叙事的一部分
第三
你是家庭品牌的资产
而不是一个独立的人
于是孩子的选择
他的伴侣
他的情感
他的痛苦
只要不利于家族的整体形象
就会被合理化的
而最残酷的地方就在于
这种否定
往往披着
我都是为你好
为家庭好的外衣
那为什么
很多父母那么成功
他越成功越难接受孩子的独立呢？
你看
这就是很多人看不懂
贝克汉姆
他们这个家庭反映的地方
他们拥有名望
拥有财富
拥有地位
按道理来说
对吧
他应该更从容啊
但心理学告诉我们
恰恰相反
一个人在外部世界
获得越多的身份价值
就越容易在亲密关系当中失去弹性
因为孩子的独立
在潜意识里边
常常会被解读为
控制力的
尤其是当父母早年把大量的情感意义
甚至未完成的自我价值
都投射到孩子身上的时候
那么当孩子结婚
他建立新家庭
开始把伴侣放在优先位置的时候
在父母的潜意识里边
这不是成长
而是一种
于是控制升级
干预升级
边界进一步被践踏
所以在布鲁克林发的这段长文里边
有句话
几乎被所有的媒体反复的引用
但常常被轻描淡写的带过
他说的是类似这么一句话
他说
我跟你们说
这不是一句情绪化的指责
而是一句反复确认过立场后的总结呀
那很多人听到这
他会本能的说一句
这不很正常吗？
儿媳妇本来就不是血亲啊
但恰恰就是这句很正常
在心理学上
杀伤力非常的强
因为从心理层面看
这句话传递的从来
不是一个家庭的立场
而是一个极其清晰
也极其冷酷的信号
第一
第二
第三
注意
在这被否定的
不是他老婆
儿媳这个人
而是你作为一个成年人
你为自己人生做选择的
所以从心理发展的角度
一个成年人真正成熟的标志
并不是经济独立
而是完成三件事
第一件事
第二
第三
而婚姻
正是这个阶段
最核心的心理动作之一
当父母说出
她不是家人这句话的时候
在潜意识的层面
其实是在说
你现在做的这个决定
不具备进入我们系统的资格
这是一种人格层级的否定
等同于在说
你的人生
依然需要我来批准
很多父母没有意识到一件事
就是
当你否定孩子的伴侣
你其实是在逼孩子
在心理学上这叫做
关系二选一的压力
所以你们看这件事情的本质
其实是一场布鲁克林的
但是你看在健康的家庭系统里边
有一个非常重要的原则
父母系统
与孩子建立的新家庭系统
在情感上
应当是
但是当父母坚持
谁算家人由我说了算
其实就是在拒绝承认
孩子
新系统的合法性
那这就意味着
谁能进这个家的边界
是我决定的
谁值得被尊重是我来定义的
你的选择
只在我同意的范围内成立
那从边界理论来看
这就是典型的
加上
而当一个成年人反复感受到
我的人生边界在你这无效
那我告诉你
人的大脑会启动两种反应
要么就是服从
要么就切断
所以你们看在现实当中
布鲁克林只剩下两条路啊
第一条路
继续留在贝克汉姆
这个家庭系统里边
那就意味着他必须在情感上
在立场上
在现实行动上
对伴侣进行某种程度的牺牲和背叛
那么第二条路
退出原有的家庭系统
把主要的情感忠诚
身份认同
心理归属转移到自己的新家庭里边
而拉黑
到仇亲
那不就是第二种反应的情绪外显吗
在现实生活里边
很多人误解了
他不是不爱
而是不再自我牺牲
我相信真正经历过这类家庭的人
他心里都非常清楚一件事
他们不是没有给过机会
他们忍过
退让过
解释过
妥协过
甚至一次次的说服自己
算了
他们年纪大了
他们也是第一次做父母
算了
只要我再懂事一点
直到有一天身体先扛不住了
焦虑
抑郁
情绪麻木
关系功能障碍
对亲密关系的恐惧
这个时候仇亲
他不是情绪的爆发
而是一个孩子
自我保护的最后一道闸门呐
如果说你把布鲁克林的
行为理解为控诉父母
那我告诉你
你会错过最重要的一层心理的意义
真正关键的是这一点
他不再接受
你是谁由我们决定了
这不是对父母的攻击
而是对旧家庭系统退出的声明啊
在心理学上
这叫做
就是
一个孩子终于从
这一步
几乎注定是痛的呀
因为它意味着
你会失去一些
你曾经以为理所当然的关系
那我相信我讲到了这
很多同学心里边都会冒出一个问题
那我该怎么办?
难道只能一直断联
一直对抗
一直恨下去吗?
如果说答案
只有
那仇亲就只是一种情绪的宣泄
而不是
但心理学
尤其是我们讲的
从来不是让你困在过去算账
而是帮助你
往前推
那么在这有一个非常重要
也常被误解的概念
就是
仇亲之所以让人痛苦
不是因为你恨父母
而是因为你
一边还被困在了
要他们变好的
期待里边
在心理学里边
有个非常形象的说法
叫
巨婴不是指幼稚撒娇
而是指身体已经成年
但是大脑
还卡在父母的系统里边
那这类人内心常常有一种
很隐蔽
却很耗能的心理对白
你们当年没做到的
现在必须补给我
你们必须
变成我理想中的父母
我才愿意真正的成长
结果就变成了人已经成年
但是心里
一直停在跟父母算账的阶段
所以从NLP的角度来看
这就是一种关系断线
但心里还没有真正分离的状态
表面上是断联是仇亲
内在
他还是一个
他没办法顺利的走向
我为自己的人生负责
你看很多关于亲子的内容
一上来就
但我们的立场不是这样
在谈任何修复之前
有一句话必须先放在最前面
你对父母的不满很可能都是真的
你不需要为了成长
先否认自己的伤
那些被控制被羞辱
被忽视被牺牲
要求懂事
这些都是真实发生过的事
承认痛苦
不等于永远停在痛苦里
但否认痛苦
才会让你一辈子走不出来呀
所以接下来我们来讲讲
仇亲解法里边
最关键的一步
我们需要把两件事
彻底的分开
第一个
生活层次指的就是
他们怎样干预你的
感情婚姻人生的选择
那些控制
对吧
羞辱
忽视打骂越界
具体的行为
那些让你痛苦愤怒
想要逃离的真实经历
这些
你完全有权利不接受
你可以生气
你可以保持距离
你可以选择不再进入同样的关系模式
那么第二个我们叫
生命层次你必须接受
生命层次只谈一件事
我的生命
是经由他们传递而来
这件事不讨论他们做的好与不好
爱与不爱你
尽不尽责
只承认一个事实
你已经活在这个世界上了
那从心理学的角度
这一步不是为了父母
而是为了你
能把系统往前推呀
当你能在心里边说出这句话
在生命这件事上
我接受他们是我的父母
那我告诉你
你就完成了一次非常重要的
过去的伤害
我以后慢慢处理
但从现在开始
我不再否认
这条生命
我要用它
为未来
做更好的选择
所以
NLP的技术
它是一门永远面向未来的心理学
它不会问
“他们当年对你做错了什么？”
而是问
你现在已经长大了
从这一刻起
你想用这条生命
走向哪里？
所以接受父母
不是说让你回头忍耐
而是为了让你不再把一生的力气
耗在对过去的反应里边
所以最后给大家三句话
可以天天用的
当你能够反复对自己说出这3句话
你就会发现仇亲的力量
开始慢慢的松动
不是说因为父母变好了
而是你终于把自己人生的主控权
拿回来了呀
如果你在听我们今天内容的时候
心里边隐隐作痛
如果你也被曾说成
冷血自私不孝翅膀硬了
那我想对你说一句非常重要的话
你不是坏孩子
你只是不想再用一生
去偿还不属于你的债
你回到贝克汉姆一家这一次的事件
你会发现一个很残酷
也很真实的事实
哪怕是在看起来光鲜成功
被世界羡慕的家庭里边
当一个孩子的边界长期被忽视
被踩踏
当他的人生选择始终得不到承认
关系最终
也会走到断裂的那一天
这不是谁赢谁输
而是一个人终于意识到
如果我再不为自己站起来
我这一辈子
都会活在别人的系统里
关注
更多心理学的知识
每天都在更新
也感谢大家的
真正成熟的亲子关系从来都不是牺牲
不是谁为谁忍一辈子
而是
当爱
必须以压抑服从
自我否定为代价
那已经不再是爱
而是
所以
当一个家庭始终拒绝
承认你的边界的时候
当你再怎么努力
都只能被要求再懂事一点
那么有时候
并不是背叛父母
而是你这一辈子里边
第一次
真正的为自己负责
也许这一步很痛
也许他不被理解
但他意味着
你终于开始
把这条生命
交回到
自己的手里了